do you go on only fans at all I know I
logged on one night and then I logged
off you know I'm trying to stay off a
masturbation stay off a touch of my own
weiner really yeah I don't I don't need
to do it I'm doing cool you know I feel
better when I don't do it
is it masturbation or pornography well
yeah pornography I think is nice to stay
away from we talked about this before
because my thought was just that it and
you said it's fun it's just people that
abuse it you know so I think like
I I just I don't like to have those
thoughts in my head it keeps it keeps me
thinking too much sexual side and not
enough like connection side right right
that's the number one criticism of
people who watch pornography is that it
yeah it makes you think sexually instead
of like romantic yeah and if I want to
have a family and stuff I have to have
more like you know Rio intrinsic kind of
romantic connection thoughts and and I
have to be able to control my not
control my membrane but let my nature
come through that way not think like I
want to recreate some [ __ ] I saw in a
film right right or yeah you know I
don't even do I don't even think that
way but like your subconscious just
whole it remembers the stuff you know
and it kind of Mills around in there
just kind of loiters around your brain
and Dick a little how many girls have
started to make a living off of only
fans now that would just normally have a
job and never get paid the same amount
of money well it's one of the reasons
why we're not seeing that many hot
chicks working at Chipotle I think is
that what it is I had the only fans I
think it's gonna it's definitely but how
do they get an audience
like just because you're hot and you
show your [ __ ] they bait through
their Instagram yeah
those two [ __ ] are the same is that
true I'm sure it's like a fingerprint
they're gonna use that from now on to
get into the bank
it's like you're retina scan that's how
do you get into Dan bilzerian's house
laughs
I mean if you really think about how
many girls are making like stupendous
amounts of money on only fans oh it's
baffling but do you do you also think
Joe that whoa only fans is over 1
million creators so one well let's
imagine that's an that's worldwide
up from 70 000 in 2019. so all those
people jumped on board during the
pandemic
that makes sense this is what I start to
worry about that it's going to be like
every what is this called a gig economy
no what is this okay no gig economy is
like uber okay is it would you think of
only fans does that count yeah I mean
you could get a gig they could make a
video for a specific person same kind of
thing do you think it's gonna get to a
point right where
if we start losing jobs right and
there's less jobs and more people are on
like only fans right that you're
basically going to have chicks out there
like literally people women holding each
other at gunpoint like you know
subscribe to my [ __ ] stuff like that
like
you know what I'm saying like I don't
know what you're saying you know help
Jamie can you pull up some help
I need some help man like I always have
this vision of like two Uber drivers
like you're you're gonna be my uh
um I'm your you're my ride or you know
what I'm saying you're my like
it's like people like it's all just
digital it's all online and it's just
like people just like subscribe to me
now you know like literally at gunpoint
like that's how bad it's gonna get I
don't think that's gonna happen but I
think there's gonna be a lot of people
that are doing that to make a living the
problem is where's the money coming from
is it going to be subscribers paying
other subscribers is it going to be like
a hierarchy like someone who makes like
a million dollars a month paying someone
who makes a hundred thousand dollars a
month who pays someone who makes ten
thousand dollars a month is it is it
going to be a pyramid scheme for [ __ ]
yeah
I I yeah I'd almost get to buy a fake
[ __ ] somewhere and put it out there I
don't think that's good enough I think
you have to have the whole body attached
to it like what do most girls on only
fans do do they show like bikini
pictures like what are they doing
showing feet there's bikini pictures I
know that there's like meetups where
like manager companies like have them
all go to like a location together like
at the beach and then they do like you
know tit touching and like uh
you know uh they get together smelling
each other's cry you know like stuff oh
and so that gets everybody excited and
then they get more like so they have
math animals do like stuff animals do
before their owner pulls them away real
quick I heard that a lot of these girls
with their when they're interacting with
people online they're not really doing
it that they hire a company and then
someone writes these letters because
like if you feel like you're gonna
respond to people and text them like how
many of them are you gonna do this to
like how many can you how many days I
mean how much hours in the day do you
have and if people don't know how many
you're responding to or who's doing it
like if you have like say if you have a
million subscribers on only fans and you
get a hundred thousand messages a month
yeah you gotta have somebody helping you
maybe they just have a person like a
service who writes like sexy things like
thank you sweetie heart heart yeah kiss
blowing kiss you know yeah like yeah
you're so sweet thank you and he's a fat
guy writing those things
you know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one